[Music]  Riverdale stars Lily Reinhart and Cole  Sprouse share a kiss in Paris bug-head  fans rejoice the pair may have just  confirmed they're a couple in real life  the actors who play Riverdale's Betty  Cooper and Jughead Jones were spotted  sightseeing in the city of love on  Monday after their first ever River con  a convention for fans of the CW show  looking happy and tres chic lillian  Kolber seen walking side by side and  sharing a sweet streetside smooch the  adorable duo first sparked dating rumors  in july 2017 after Lily and Cole were  reportedly seen kissing and holding  hands during their trip to comic-con  [Music]  she that's fun for me Ichi spoke with  Lily just one month later where she  gushed over all of her Riverdale  co-stars I work with my best friends and  that's rare and I'm just again just  these are my best friends like I'm here  with my best friends and can I say best  friends one more time yeah  [Music]  [Applause]